fuertes enfrentamientos entre la policía
y militantes ecologistas se produjeron
esta mañana en las afueras de la sala
pleyel de París donde tenía lugar la
junta de accionistas de la petrolera
francesa total estaban allí Para apoyar
a diecisiete accionistas minoritarios de
la empresa muchos de ellos también
ecologistas que presentaron un proyecto
de resolución no obligatoria para que la
empresa vaya más lejos en sus ambiciones
para luchar contra el cambio climático
yendo de sus compromisos según ellos si
la empresa no hace más justamente por
reducir las emisiones que producen el
gas y el petróleo que vende a otras
personas No se lograrán los objetivos
del acuerdo del clima de París que
quiere limitar el alza de las
temperaturas del planeta en uno coma
cinco grados por eso la policía terminó
expulsándolos de frente del teatro al
interior el gerente de la empresa dijo
que esta resolución no servía pidió a
los accionistas que votaran en contra de
ella y dijo que iba contra los
accionistas pero también contra los y
contra la transición ecológica Pues a su
juicio total será un gran actor y lo
está haciendo Ya según él de esta
transición ecológica los accionistas
parecen haberle hecho caso porque
finalmente rechazaron esta resolución
por un
88,7% de los votos la primera ministra
Elizabeth envió un mensaje de apoyo a
los manifestantes dijo que tenían su
derecho de alertar sobre algo que les
parece que no está bien por su parte la
ministra de transición también presionó
nuevamente a total para que vaya más
lejos en sus ambiciones